hello let's get started so my name is
John Salvatore and I'm going to be
presenting I'm going to be presenting on
PI MC 3 let's see the clothes that the
way I'm going to be presenting on pi mc3
and probabilistic programming in general
but mostly focusing on high mc3 weird
wait so first a little bit about me I am
the author of the most recent PI mc3
rewrite from PI NC 2 2 pi M C 3 I used
to work at Amazon up until a little
while ago and I am the founder of
Seattle effective altruists which is a
local chapter of more global movement of
people who are very excited about
figuring out how to maximize the amount
of good they do in the world and like
focusing a lot on statistical evidence
and careful reasoning and trying to be
extremely willing to change your mind as
and so forth so first what is
probabilistic programming our ballistic
programming is when you write a program
that generates data that is like your
data and then there are well-known ways
of turning a program that can generate
data that's like your data and being
able to do inference for the parameters
that parameterize your program and PI
mc3 is basically Bayesian probabilistic
programming it allows you to write very
short and clear very short and clear
models and do extremely simple inference
that are just require a few lines of
code and so don't require a high level
of skill or substantial knowledge about
Bayesian statistics etc and so recently
there was a rewrite of PI MC 2 into PI
MC 3 that we rewrote it in terms of Fae
on O or built around theano which is a
computational graph library that
supports automatic differentiation and
allows us to work on much bigger models
than you otherwise could with Markov
chain Monte Carlo sampling so I'm going
to contrast PI MC a bit with what I call
black box machine learning so it one one
method that's popular in data science
right now is to use like random forests
etc or like pre-canned models that you
don't necessarily understand that well
but you don't necessarily understand
that well to go from your data and you
do some feature selection and then you
get output of predictions but it's not
always very clear like what the model is
doing on the inside and if you like want
to change how the model works you're
relatively limited in what you can do so
I think there like three main
distinctions between black box ml and
probabilistic programming so black box
it's like pretty opaque you have this
algorithm that all right you didn't
write somebody else wrote so you're like
not real sure about how it works
and if you want to but in probabilistic
programming it's like very clear you
know exactly like how and why your model
works you're a lot more constrained in
black box ml like I said just a minute
ago if you want to change the model it's
not clear how to do that and like
without really digging into the
internals and like maybe making it
totally new algorithm etc but in
probabilistic programming it's basically
it's a lot more like
building blocks where you can just put
different things together to fit like
the situation at hand fit the data that
you exactly have in your like knowledge
about that data and then random forests
and so forth often don't end up giving
you uncertainty estimates or at least
not very good uncertainty estimates but
probabilistic programming and pmc in
general lets you have like full
uncertainty estimates full probability
distributions over the things that you
are inferring whether its parameters for
your model or your actual predictions so
I have this analogy between Bapat for
sort of black box ml and Legos for pi MC
so pop it it basically has one function
you can play with it in one particular
way and if you want to play with it in a
different way you'd like don't have that
many options
whereas Legos like you can build the
exact toy that you want if you want
something different you can like take it
apart and build something new and that
works great it's not very hard and pop
it also has these like knobs and stuff
that you're like not exactly sure how
they work and you're not sure how like
how it works on the inside but Legos
there's like no question you know how it
works and it's like very easy to see
like what makes it tick I also want to
keep in mind to to trends in data
science so one is the trend from
hypothesis testing towards estimating
things with uncertainty and the other is
the trend from frequentist or like ad
hoc methods to like fully Bayesian
treatments and pmc basically allows you
to do it like fits very naturally with
both of those in that it's basically all
about estimating things with uncertainty
and also it's of course fully Bayesian
so next what I'm going to do
I'm going to go over a pretty simple
model this is like the canonical PI MC
model in PI and c3 and we're going to
look at this coal mining data or coal
mining disaster data over about a
hundred year timespan and we're going to
do switch point analysis which if you
look at the left hand side of the data
versus kind of the right hand side it
seems clear that at some point there was
like on the left hand side that there
were a lot like higher disaster counts
on the y-axis is disaster like number of
disasters in that year and you can see
that like until like in 1900 there were
a lot more disasters per year and then
somehow that like kind of fizzled out
where there were many fewer disasters in
later years so at some point that
changed but it's like not clear when in
fact there was some legislation I think
sort of around 1900s so it'd be nice to
know like me like was that the cause of
it of this change or like maybe it was
due to something else and we're also
kind of uncertain about like what the
mean rate what the mean rate for
disasters was in this early period
versus this late period so there are
three parameters that we're uncertain
about one is like when this time change
happened or when this switch happened
and another another is what was the
design what was the rate of disasters in
the early period and what was the rate
of disasters in the later period and you
can do this kind of analysis with a lot
of different kinds of data kam Davidson
who's giving a talk next period about
mistakes that I've made the mistake that
he's made
he's developing a talk based on talks
that mistakes that I've made but so he
has he has replicated something very
similar to this but with its in PI mc2
and is on his own text messaging data
you can also imagine doing this kind of
analysis on it like website traffic or
like click-through rates over time etc
so it like you can apply this kind of
analysis to a lot of different things so
I'm gonna next I'm going to show you the
PI mc3 model this is basically this is
the whole model specification it doesn't
do the fitting but this is basically all
of what we're going to use to model that
datum and so the first thing that we're
going to do is define a new model using
the width statements and everything
inside this context is associated with
that with that model that we are calling
disaster model so anything that takes
place within that with statement is
automatically associated with that the
reason we do that is so that we don't
have to manually associate everything
because that gets confusing and verbose
so the first so the first thing that
we're gonna add after that we're going
to define all of the unknown quantities
that we have about our model so the
first thing that we talked about is the
switch point or like when in this data
this change occurred from like a high
disaster regime to a low disaster regime
we're like not sure when that happened
and in particular here we're saying that
that we're very uncertain we're just
using a uniform distribution to discrete
uniform distribution and that's alright
like before looking at the data that is
our uncertainty like in any any year for
the switch point is equally likely
and then the next thing that we do is we
define our to disaster rates early mean
and late mean the early mean is for the
left-hand side or like the left-hand
side on the left side of the switch
point and the late mean is the
right-hand side and we're using
exponential prior distributions
basically just to say that lower values
seem sort of more realistic to us lower
disaster rates seem more realistic
just before we like really look at this
data or anything and exponential I think
they they have a scale of 1 so we'll
probably quickly get updated towards
higher values since they seem to have
higher than that and then
so once we've defined those 3 unknown
quantities and their prior distributions
we switch to now we want to compute like
the overall rate for like for every year
what is the rates of disasters taking
place and we do that defining the rate
variable and we use the switch function
which is a little bit like an if
statement in faaaan oh you'll also
notice that the things I guess it's less
clear here but Theano is a lot like
numpy and you can like write your models
basically as if you were generating fake
data in numpy so like for it for this
switch point I would like pull a random
uniform number between lower and there
like a maximum number of years and then
the early mean I would like like make a
random exponential distribution draw on
the same thing for the late distribution
and then yeah so for all the years where
the year is larger than the suit point
is switch point the year is just like
from like 1 to 100 and
leaven or whatever the number of data
points that I have it's just a numpy
array every year that that's every year
that that's larger than the switch point
we're going to use the late mean and for
everything that's lower than the switch
point we're going to use the early mean
so now we have for each for each year
we've defined our rate and now we're
actually going to the the last thing
that we do is add our actual beta which
is stored in disaster data which I
didn't define here but it's defined
above and so because this is Count data
it makes sense to use a Poisson
distribution just the distribution over
discrete larger than zero and it takes a
rate it takes like a mean value which
we're passing in this rate for each year
and then the observed the disaster data
is just a numpy array of although it
could be also be a pandas array but in
this case the numpy array of of the
disaster the number of disasters
observed in each year so that's it
that's our model and so now we want to
is there anything that was like super
unclear about that the means are like
the the mean rate yeah it's like how
many disasters like the expected number
of disasters in a year and it's not so
it's not just the mean for that period
it's not just like like you took it and
summed it up in the divided by the count
it's like an unknown quantity that we're
trying to estimate
so this is all there is to doing the
inference so again we're doing
everything under the context of that
does that our disaster model and the
first thing that we're going to do is
basically draw a lot of samples from our
posterior distribution over the
parameters which is basically like the
probability distribution that we use to
describe our uncertainty after we've
observed the data we're still uncertain
about the values for these parameters
but we're still uncertain but we're like
less uncertain than we used to be and so
we have a probability distribution over
the what those parameters are and so
here we have our three the three
variables of interest so the the first
one is the early mean or like for the
left-hand side of the data and you can
see that we're guessing it looks like
the data indicate that it's like
somewhere between 2.5 and like 3.5
disasters per year in that earlier in
that earlier period and then in the in
the late period in the late period it
seems to be between between like 0.6 and
like 1.2 the things on the right are
sort of it's like a very simple
diagnostic tool of like all of the
samples that we drew to see if so we can
you can see if it's like highly
correlated yep
yeah it would probably it would probably
be not exactly like the average of the
two but something like the average of
the two the uncertainty would be less
but it like probably wouldn't if you
like plotted the residuals or something
you would see that it probably would is
like not that great of a fit no not and
then the last variable that we're doing
is the switch point or like which year
which year there was a changeover and if
you look at this
it seems like most of the probability is
concentrated between alright do you have
your hand up okay and most of the
probability is between most of the
probability is between 35 and 40 or so
and like maybe a little bit higher than
40 and if we like go look back at this
data if we go look back at this data
that I think that ends up being
somewhere in like this region but it's
actually like a pretty narrow region
yeah I should have put those actual
numbers up there but what was your
question
it's just because switch point is
discrete yeah yeah and then I made this
graph with the trace plot function so
that's and just like told at which
variables to graph yeah you don't
actually have to specify them here but
you can I say that again yep basically
yeah yeah that's like that's what you
want them to look like him
there are quantified versions we have
some of them yep oh yes that's a good
point thank you
yes so nuts which is that called a No
u-turn sampler is the more sophisticated
algorithm that lets us fit large large
problems at large meaning many many
unknown variables which this problem
actually doesn't have however it only
works on continuous variables not
discrete variables and so we also have
to add metropolis which does handle
discrete variables yep cross function
how do I know that it's getting better
like how do I know that my fit is
getting better so the loss function is
just the like the posterior density for
the so basically we can compute the
posterior density for like any given
parameters for for any like choice of
these three parameters we can calculate
like according to our prior distribution
and according to the data likelihood
that we had which is this disasters
place on thing
like the density of probability there
and then the two step methods metropolis
and nuts are designed to like converge
the correct distribution here it does
that make sense
some maybe we can talk afterwards yeah
are the questions I think I mean so it
is it is possible to I mean it this so
actually the switch point is like
somewhat bimodal right so yes that is
okay if you see that or if you suspect
that that's going to be true about your
model those kinds of models are often
more difficult to fit and so you like
have to be more subtle about how you do
the modeling because it's often
difficult for the step methods to go
from one mode to the other if like in
between the modes is it like extremely
unlikely well yeah and I think it's just
a line graph too so like it connects so
it connects them plus it like in the
middle like there is a connection there
it's just like less yeah yeah
yeah yep yeah I think of this like
looking at this you're like oh yeah that
seems fine yeah is it these are these
are happy sometimes you end up look at
with less happy looking ones than
sometimes need to tweak things bigger
yeah curvy often indicates that you like
you need to add more samples or figure
out a tweak to make it simple more
efficiently okay so that's basically
this model I'm going to give an example
of a different model just to kind of but
I'm not going to go that much into depth
on but to give an idea of some of the
the power behind the no u-turn sampler
basically so this the data that we're
going to use here is one year of or a
bit more than a year of sp500 data and
in particular we're going to be you'll
notice that like there's a lot of change
happening here it like moves very
rapidly but then at other times it seems
to be moving very slowly and like
there's not very much change so at like
how fast a stock or an index changes in
finances like known as volatility and so
like this volatility seems to be
changing over time sometimes it's really
low sometimes or sometimes just really
high sometimes it's really low at other
times it's like sort of in the middle so
it like changes over time and it would
be nice to be able to track this over
time because it gives you some idea of
like how risky things are and it can
like it lets you do better forecasting
for like risk forecasting or like risk
metrics so we are going to model this
we're going to model this with a
stochastic process that basically like
models models the the ball
Tilla t as a time-series that that like
drifts over time and we're going to like
estimate all of the parameters that go
into both the both the returns here and
then also they go into like this
volatility process so this is this is
the model I'm not going to go too much
into depth on this model model other
than to point out that it's also not
that complicated
basically I'm defining five different
random variables yeah five different
random variables and in particular the
the the time series that we've defined
is like using this Gaussian random walk
here that's how we define that and it
has so it has a shape of N and here is
400 or like the length of the time
series and so there are actually four
hundred different random variables that
we are modeling in there and with most
most Bayesian framework it's quite
difficult to sample it like it do good
sampling over over your model when you
have that many variables when you have
like hundreds or thousands of variables
that turns out to be extremely slow and
inefficient but the no u-turn sampler
handles that with a plum and allows us
to fit it efficiently and we're also
something that we're doing that is not
really possible with other methods is to
say that the returns for the sp500 are T
distributed instead of normally
distributed it's like common to common
two to assume that the distribution of
returns for a stock or an index or
something are normally distributed but
that's actually a horrible assumption
and like T fits because they you have
like much fatter tails and like T helps
you like take account to those fatter
tails and like understand the situation
better and estimate estimate things
better so we're doing here and we're
like s
maiding the degrees of freedom for that
as well and so forth so here I'm gonna
skip the actual inference step that's
not that different it's a little bit
more complicated but but you can find
this in the tutorial that I'll post at
the end so this is our probability
distribution over the stochastic process
that we end up with so this is 400
different random variables and I've
basically taken like a whole bunch of
samples of this random time series and
then plotted them with some with some
alpha such that you can see the
uncertainty and so you can see like in
this period of like high volatility like
we also estimate that that like the
volatility seems to be way way higher
than in other periods and like likewise
you can see sort of this like medium
volatility is also and also like the
uncertainty goes up in those periods
considerably and you can sort of see it
change over time
so now that you've gotten kind of a
picture of like what pine sees capable
of I'm going to talk a little bit more
about that
so the like the three main benefits of
pi mc3 are you have an extremely
powerful model specification syntax
basically like any kind of model that
you could write using numpy operations
and like some other operations in Python
you can model that like you can put that
into your statistical model and like use
it to figure out the parameters that are
generating that so like Fano has like
broadcasting and it has like matrix
operations and like yeah it's like
linear linear algebra stuff and like all
the stuff that is associated numpy
basically and you can do full Bayesian
inference on this and it's like
reasonably reasonably efficient for even
like relatively large models not like a
big data large but like large with like
thousands of parameters yeah so like a
state of the art methods be the no
u-turn sampler and then we are in the
process of building a variational
inference there's there's like been some
new papers and there's a variational
inference came up with like a very
interesting new algorithm that allows us
to scale much better even and then
there's some other interesting features
that like may be interesting to people
so you can very easy to define custom
operations and distributions using using
piano or or Python you can just like
wrap Python into Theano and so it's like
very flexible about like doing whatever
you want to do you can make your own
likelihood functions you can make your
own functions that like transfer that
transform things you can handle missing
values very easily with pandas in fact
this model actually I didn't say but
disaster data has like some missing data
and I just like didn't talk about it
very much or didn't talk about it so
it's actually it's very easy just to
like have a pandas array with like some
some Nan's in it and then like throw
that into your model and it'll just
integrate over those missing values and
like try out all the different values
that it thinks it could be we also have
good support for generalized linear
models so for linear models there's like
a very nice are syntax if you're
familiar with if you've like done
modeling in are you will have these like
little strings that lets you specify
your model very compactly and we
basically also support that support that
here but with a full uncertainty like
you get back full uncertainty
distributions and like I said
variational inference is also coming
soon and will probably also be adding
Gaussian better Gaussian process support
right now it's like not that hard to
hack your own but Phi mc2 has built-in
support and so we're going to add
built-in support yep yep yeah in fact
like what happened here this this is the
posterior like I could have graphed it
I could have graphed it like this but
with 400 of these like plots but I'm
assuming that you prefer that I didn't
do that so that's this is just like an
easier way of graphing that that gives
gives like an intuitive feel for it how
it works see yes so there's some further
resources kam Davison also has a book
Bayesian bayesian methods for hackers I
think I think I'm miss miss quoting that
but that does PI mc2 that's like pretty
similar to this so it's
like a little bit different but it'll
give you a good feel for how to do this
and I think it's also in the process of
being being written or like being
rewritten for pi MC 3 I think some
people are like transferring all of the
examples and so forth and then I also
want to give a shout-out to Chris Fonz
Beck and Thomas wiki who are also on the
dev team for pi MC 3 and who are
indispensable and do a ton of work and
in fact Chris started the project yep
questions sorry say that again I mean if
you have legacy code that is that is
like already in production and you're
like using it a lot and stuff then
unless you want to like take advantage
of some of the things that PI and c3 has
then I would just like not do it it's
but if you're like looking to like
expand the model the models are so short
that like you can just like rewrite you
can just like rewrite it with like
without that much difficulty is my
suggestion and like we're very
responsive on Stack Overflow or if the
issues list if you like run into
problems and you're like I'm not sure
how to model this then we'll we'll let
you view support other questions yeah
pros and cons so you can call out to
Python so I haven't used pi stand that
much you can call out to Python more
easily I don't know if it's I assume
it's possible somehow in Stan Stan also
doesn't support discrete variables at
all whereas like we do it doesn't
support discrete variables Stan might be
a bit faster so there's like a pro and
they have a bigger dev team so you like
might get more support or something
although we try to be very supportive
other questions
sorry can you can you speak up so it
like didn't get all of that got it so if
your uncertainty ends up just being like
a normal distribution then like doing
sensitivity analysis probably works out
for you pretty decently because it's
just like you get like the first
derivatives or the second derivatives
and like that tells you like how wide
that normal distribution is but if it's
not a very normal distribution which I
think like it's surprising it like that
you get non normal posterior
surprisingly often especially when you
get into like hierarchical modeling and
stuff where it'll just be like not like
those uncertainty estimates are not real
basically that was another benefit
actually of IMC or Bayesian
probabilistic programming like Bayesian
probabilistic programming and actually
more generally is that you can do
hierarchical modeling hierarchical
modeling where when you have a lot of
when you have a lot of groups that have
like small numbers of samples within
them but you have a lot of them you can
get to better estimates for like values
for the for like the mean of like the
individual groups by doing partial
pooling which is as far as I understand
it not something that like Big Data that
like larger algorithms random forests
etc don't like there's not a way to do
that as far as I'm concerned or as far
as as far as I know whereas it's very
straightforward to do in PMC and stand
and so forth and it can be like like
depending it for for some datasets it's
extremely useful
more questions nope
cool well thank you very much and yeah
I'm talking if you